bonjour thomas porte merci d'être ce
matin avec nous ont rappelé un instant
les chiffres à la sncf 365 cheminots
testé positif aux convives 19 les
mesures de protection ont elles été
renforcées au sein de la sncf
récemment non elles n'auront pas été
renforcée parce que comme tous les
secteurs on souffre d'un manque de
produits c'est-à-dire de masques de gl
de lingettes pour désinfecter les
cabinets et les chiffres sont à la
hausse puisque aujourd'hui on a plus de
418 cheminots qui sont positifs aux
colis de 19 ce qui est un taux de
contamination qui est huit fois
supérieur à la moyenne nationale pour
les cheminots donc c'est extrêmement
inquiétant mais est ce qu'on demande
c'est que la sncf prenne des mesures de
précaution et protège les salariés du
service public qui vont travailler pour
assurer la continuité du service
depuis quand vous demandez cela et
quelles sont les réponses que vous avez
aujourd'hui de la part de notre
direction
on a peu de réponses de la direction et
des les annonces des moniales macro on
avait demandé que les mesures de
protection à l'égard des cheminots sont
de très haut niveau
la direction de la sncf déjà dans
certaines régions a mis plus de trois
jours entre le début du confinement
annoncée par le président et les mesures
qu'elle a appliquée en région donc on a
pris beaucoup de retard et aujourd'hui
on se rend compte que dans certains
endroits du territoire notamment sur les
travaux
la direction de la sncf est en train
d'organiser la reprise du travail avec
un chantage à l'emploi en disant que si
les travaux ne sont pas fait ça sera
repris dans le privé donc c'est
totalement inacceptable et aujourd'hui
on a des des procédures qui sont qui
vont à l'encontre des mesures sanitaires
qui s'en réclament à juste titre par le
gouvernement et par tous les médecins de
ce pays
non nous on demande vraiment que seules
les activités essentielles soit
maintenue et que les cheminots qui vont
travailler qu'ils ont la conscience de
service public soit protégé au même
titre que les soignants ou que les
caissiers les routiers de ce pays c'est
pas acceptable de livrer des salariés
d'une entreprise publique ou privée
quelle qu'elle soit à des dangers à les
exposer à des risques de mort est clair
on parle de morts aujourd'hui thomas
porte quelles sont les conditions
aujourd'hui de travail des cheminots on
se rappelle bien évidemment de ces
scènes de guerre complètement bondé il
ya quinze jours au début du
du confinement avec des trains remplis
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez adapté
votre travail aux mesures de de
confinement justement - trains - de
moins de travailleurs moins de cheminots
et moins de voyageurs aussi
oui effectivement le trafic a été
extrêmement réduit sera bonne à
aujourd'hui à peu près 18 % de ter et
une quarantaine de tgv qui circulent par
jour en france alors que d'habitude à
cette sainte donc effectivement beaucoup
moins de cheminots qui sont au travail
mais la réduction du plan de transport
elle a aussi amené des situations on a
des trains qui sont quand même surchargé
et où les gens ne respectent pas les 1 m
de sécurité donc il faut aussi réfléchir
à tout ça et vous savez les gars a
toujours été des lieux de contamination
très fort et on s'aperçoit que dans les
pays qui sont venus à bout ou quasiment
à bout de l'épidémie ducobu dont part de
la corée du sud sur le lait sur la
question des transports collectifs
il y avait une désinfection totale des
cabinets des trains après chaque
utilisation et malheureusement
aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas totalement
en france on n'a pas les bons de
lingettes on n'a pas les bons produits
donc il faut vraiment faire attention
parce que ça peut être facteur de
contamination très importantes aussi
bien d'ailleurs pour les cheminots que
pour les usagers qui prennent le train
tous les jours
est ce que la sncf justement faire en
sorte que ces mesures de confinement
soit respecté que vous avez à peu près
répondu à cette question mais mais pour
la santé des voyageurs de ne pas mettre
tout le monde à côté les uns des autres
et puis éviter les contrôles je ne sais
pas comment ça se passe racontez-nous au
quotidien effectivement déjà on a là on
a la quasi totalité des biches et qui
sont fermées donc les gens prennent les
bills a débord donc ça évite d'avoir du
contact personnel on a beaucoup on a
plus quasiment personne sur les quais
j'ai donc effectivement vous croisez
beaucoup moins se demandent aujourd'hui
quand vous prenez un train dans une gare
qu'est ce que le cas habituel mais je
crois que c'est pas encore suffisant il
faut encore accéléré et surtout moi je
tiens il faut protéger les cheminots qui
travaillent aujourd'hui c'est pas c'est
pas la hauteur de ce qui se fait dans
d'autres professions
et il ya des droits d'alerté qui sont
déposés par différents syndicats pour
dénoncer ces situations il faut que tous
les cheminots sur quelques chantiers
qu'il soit s'ils ne sentent pas sécurité
d'or exercé leur droit de retrait
aujourd'hui on peut pas aller au travail
la peur au ventre et on peut surtout pas
aller au travail si on n'est pas protégé
donc c'est ça qu'il faut que la
direction prenne la mesure de la
situation qu'elle assure la protection
des salariés qui travaillent en mettant
toutes les dispositions possibles pour
permettre un travail le plus sécurisé
possible si je perds m merci beaucoup
thomas porte pour toutes ces précisions
dans les gares de france merci beaucoup
thomas porte je le rappelle le
responsable du collectif des cheminots
au pcf